The clinical document architecture,
or CDA, defined HL7,
version 3 rim based documents,
assembled from administrative and
clinical data for particular purposes.
After a period of use, a consolidation
effort removed inconsistencies,
resulting in the current
consolidated CDA or CCDA standard.
Here's a particular example of some
simple patient demographic data
we'll used to show how RIM
supports CCDA documents.
While it's difficult to read,
here's the same patient data
depicted in a RIM Roll.
And we can see, for example.
The phone number here is displayed here.
Here's the data incorporated
into a CCDA document.
In this case it's the continuity
of care document or CCD.
A key electronic document for exchange
among providers at transitions of care.
When, for example, patients are admitted
to or discharged from a hospital, or
referred by a primary care
physician to a specialist.
Transitions of care
are a key risk point, so
exchanging data at them is an important
means of assuring quality and safety.